então essa foi a pergunta
escutei como doutorando em design para
que eu estivesse aqui hoje eu sempre
tive a certeza de que estaria ligado a
atividades relacionadas à criatividade
mas design era algo completamente
desconhecido para mim pensei fazer
publicidade propaganda mas a vida acabou
me levando a escolher relações públicas
eu não sabia direito o que era mas como
o nome era interessante era na
comunicação e resolvi fazer
eu literalmente e joguei agora imagine a
minha situação
ae advogado porque no interior se fala
advogado mãe psicóloga ea irmã fazendo
que advêm medicina e eu relações
públicas pudesse representar a expressão
da minha família quando eu contei o
curso escolhido com certeza seria essa a
imagem é uma menina que cresci no
interior querendo fazer um curso que
ninguém sabia o que era na capital e
ainda tendo que pagar uma fortuna para
isso
esse é o quadro e deu tudo certo tanto
que quando eu terminei a faculdade eu me
inscrevi para fazer mestrado em
comunicação social
pensei o máximo que vai acontecer é não
passar mas não é que eu passei e eu
fazendo mestrado
eu também queria integrar a área
acadêmica já estava inserida no mercado
da comunicação
foi um início difícil
foi um início meio difícil o mestrado
foi todo difícil eu trabalhava muito nos
finais de semana e precisava de tempo
além de escrever sobre tudo aquilo que
eu tava lendo não conseguia dar conta
eu pensei em desistir muitas vezes
encontrei no meu orientador
a inspiração
salvo e nunca vou esquecer quando estava
à beira de um colapso e falar em colapso
de uma platéia que tem alguns médicos e
até meio complicado mas era verdadeiro
eu estava naquela relação produção
versus prazo ea dissertação não ia
talvez alguns de vocês saibam que eu
estou falando
sabe como é eu não sabia se eu iria
continuar fazendo
foi então que no meu encontro com o
orientador
ele me deu um caloroso abraço e me disse
vai ao cinema hoje
olhei estranhei
não posso eu preciso fazer o prazo está
chegando e o que ele disse eu vou lhe
avisar que a versão final está comigo e
que eu vou demorar e vai atrasar uns 20
dias para que eu possa fazer a leitura
mas promete uma coisa este final de
semana é teu na segunda feira volta a
fazer a tua dissertação é uma atitude um
exemplo que eu levo pra vida foi uma
escuta que acreditem foi nesse mesmo
momento que eu comecei a ser professora
foi neste mesmo período que eu integrei
a universidade da qual estou até hoje
agora sim eu sou a gabriela gonçalves
comunicador a professora na indústria
criativa desde 2001 e uma super
entusiasta do design emocional
sou uma pessoa que sempre busca
inspiração em tudo que faço e que ama
escutar os outros mas eu também sou a
mulher de mauro
a mãe do rafa a irmã daniela a médica
a filha da terezinha a psicóloga pra
minha pesquisa eu fiz um workshop e é
onde eu trabalhei a inspiração em um
determinado contexto vão ser muitos
contextos para que eu possa entender a
inspiração no contexto de atividades
projetuais
neste workshop inicialmente com 11
mulheres incríveis que participaram elas
escreveram palavras define inspiração e
lá apareceu energia e motivação atitude
força construção abertura superação e
coragem e relacionando estas palavras
com a área da saúde imediatamente
lembrei de um caso que muito me inspirou
no início da pesquisa
o centro de atendimento e se propõe a
ajudar qualquer pessoa que tenha sido
afetada pelo câncer que são espalhados
pelo reino unido
elas não integram os hospitais mas ficam
bem próximos
a fundadora durante a sua luta contra o
câncer e por isso muito vulnerável
descrever os corredores hospitalares que
pareciam sem fim
os espaços brancos em janelas ou com
janelas lacradas cozinha inacessível
tudo banhado por luz faith foi por meio
da escuta desses depoimentos que este
centro foi projetado ainda nos anos 90
lá naqueles depoimentos estavam as
emoções a serem transportadas nas
pessoas quando entrassem em um ambiente
de tratamento lá estava o amce ela luz
natural pelo que o paciente esperava ver
pela janela por uma cozinha com uma mesa
para sentar com xícaras de chá para
dividir para tomar junto o shaq no reino
unido é uma super tradição talvez se
fosse aqui fosse o velho e bom chimarrão
as emoções que eram esperadas pelos
pacientes foram compreendidas
elas foram escutadas e uma realidade
mais próxima da gente temos uma ong
brasileira fundada por uma grande médica
carioca
recentemente eu estive junto com outros
organizadores sedex em um fórum que
premia empreendedores sociais
em conversa informal ela estava com a
gente eu ouvi essa grande médica
contando não adianta tratar uma criança
com pneumonia por exemplo e devolvê la a
um ambiente totalmente vulnerável
às vezes o que essa criança e essa
família precisam não é de um médico e
foi por escutar as reais necessidades
dessas crianças e suas famílias que ela
desenvolveu uma metodologia própria o
parque
o plano de ação familiar com ações que
integram áreas da saúde educação
cidadania moral de renda esse plano é
feito com cada uma das famílias em
situação de vulnerabilidade social que
possuem criança internada respeitando
toda sua realidade
uma médica que no exercício de sua
profissão relacionou as necessidades
humanas com recursos disponíveis levando
em consideração as limitações existentes
essa ong ela já recebeu diversas
premiações investimentos internacionais
e em 2017 recebeu pela sexta vez o
prêmio e reconhecimento como a mais
inovadora da américa latina
para nossa alegria essa ong também atua
em nossa cidade e no ambiente de sala de
aula como professora sempre fui
inspirada por práticas que vão além da
universidade e do mundo acadêmico sempre
tentando promover bate papos saídas de
campo tentando deixar o ambiente mais
descontraído talvez para não ter uma
aula chata com tantos anos de docência
já foram mais de 100 turmas em torno de
dois mil alunos se você já fizeram essa
conta que está há muito tempo na
docência e todos eles sem exceção já
receberam um bom quando o que eles
recebem esse bombom no dia da avaliação
individual
acredito que intuitivamente eu já estava
flertando com o design emocional porque
na verdade eu sempre busquei projetar
esse momento de avaliação que é um
momento tenso transformar isso em
emoções positivas projetar emoções
positivas os meus alunos uma avaliação
ao momento tenso para muitas pessoas e
temos a
alunos em total situação de
vulnerabilidade emocional
então por que o google porque ele ajuda
a transformar a tensão em um momento de
descontração porque ele ajuda em um
melhor desempenho no processo avaliativo
porque ele alimenta quem não pode jantar
ou tomar o seu café da manhã porque ele
significa a minha escuta em uma dimensão
bem menor mas que pra mim teve um
significado muito relevante
foi quando quando meu filho queimou a
ponta dos gases dinho's na porta do
forno e sabemos o quanto uma queimadura
art
ele estava aprendendo a caminhar e
portanto com menos de 1 ano de vida
acabou entrando na cozinha e se apoiou
no forno
como ele entrou na cozinha tinha um
portão lá como eu não vi
liguei pro teatro pedindo que fazer e
ele instruiu para que a gente brincar se
com rafa com água fria de um analgésico
para aliviar a dor
eu sabia que não era nada grave apenas
alguns dedinhos com uma bolha mas
percebendo a minha voz trêmula
ele perguntou por que essa voz
eu apenas disse que a culpa o que o faço
com essa culpa na verdade pra mim esse é
o pior naquele momento
a queimadura eu sabia que não era grave
ele acalmou me contou que situações
muito parecidas ainda poderiam acontecer
e que estava tudo bem
era o primeiro filho eram as primeiras
experiências como mãe e um pediatra
ele me escutou
o design ele pode ser aplicado em
qualquer área dimensão principalmente na
área da saúde em que as pessoas estão
muito vulneráveis em que as pessoas
clamam por serem escutadas relacionar
necessidades humanas com recursos
técnicos que estão disponíveis
levando em consideração as realidades de
cada um
isso é possível fazer isso é uma prática
de design e isso aconteceu com aquele
centro de tratamento de câncer e isso
aconteceu também na metodologia
inovadora proposta pela ong que eu
comentei com vocês e isso também reduz a
ansiedade ea tensão dos alunos em sala
de aula
a escuta promove o que chamamos de
empatia a empatia é uma ferramenta
poderosa para que a gente possa
desenvolver o pensamento e as práticas
de design e todos nós podemos fazer isso
e vocês estão dispostos a escutar alguém
hoje
muito obrigada